what's up guys i'm machine gun kelly and
you are watching
thirst tweets right here on buzzfeed
[Music]
all right the first one says colson
baker has the most beautiful smile okay
well thanks i don't know i covered my
smile up whenever i start to smile
yeah sex is cool and all but have you
heard machine gun kelly laugh
oh my god dude i don't shut up
my friend shouldn't be allowed to listen
to this it's only awkward because
i hate my smile i hate my laugh i don't
even really have much of a laugh i just
have like a mute laugh
it's hard for me to receive compliments
on things that i'm like i don't
feel you but thank you machine gun kelly
i just want to let you know
that i'm free this sunday to go on a
date just let me know if you're free
sunday because i'm free and we'd like to
take you on a date i'm locked in already
right now
no dates for me probably ever my type is
exactly
blonde 6'4 covered in tattoos and gangly
resembles a stray golden retriever could
ruin my life
through colson baker that's me aka
machine gun kelly also me
it's machining on kelly okay thank you
so much libya
which also sounds like another word
every time i unlock my phone i see that
pic of my zaddy machine gun kelly and
follow even more in love
thank you if machine gun kelly told me
to break my own arm
i 100 would do that let's play a game of
simon says up in this
i'll do anything for you i'm actually
down with that mentality i kind of like
someone who's down to die for love
life goal let machine gun kelly spit on
me jesus christ
thank you for coming to my ted talk
you're funny as well said
funny man i would let machine guard
kelly suck my toes maybe
all right like i said i'm only sucking
one pair of toes i'm trying to lick
machine gun kelly's body so much his
tattoos fade away
that's a lot of licking good luck i wish
machine gun kelly didn't look like my ex
it'd make it a lot easier for me to
masturbate to those pictures
okay that's really [ __ ] funny machine
gun kelly makes me cream
it could be cream cheese we don't know
don't use the word cream
it's like moist it makes me feel wet
when machine gun kelly said it's not
even a question whether or not i'm the
true list ever
just pressing on me to get some [ __ ] on
their acrylics i felt that because it's
true
it's a pretty out-of-pocket line good
word play places i'd like to be right
now tahiti a bank vault on machine gun
kelly's
it's a good taste tahiti cool bank
vaults are also cool
i guess the next part is subjective but
for the most part machine really is
pretty cool i want to suck
gun kelly's soul through his then spit
it back in my face
oh my god what the [ __ ] poetic
very poetic i'm gonna have to sleep on
that one i would let
colson baker and pete davidson eiffel
tower me no joke
let's turn this into something positive
here for educational purposes
an eiffel tower for those who don't know
would be
two structures
that's for another day i would pay good
money to let machine gun kelly stomp on
my head
why i don't care machine gun kelly has
the hottest hands in the entire world
and i'd pay him to choke me out
they look like hands my girl says i have
like wizard hands i know i already
tweeted this but i would let machine gun
kelly raw dog me in the backseat of my
car in the parking lot of an arby's
that's all when i was 18
that's that that was this is probably
all going on at an arby's
this is you know what's about this week
is that she goes i know i already
tweeted this so you said multiple times
that
you would let me raw dog you in the back
seat of
a car in a parking lot of an arby's
oddly specific
and shitty place to also choose to
have raw sex okay wow that was
cool weird thank you so much for all
your thirst tweets go watch project
power out on netflix
and uh take us to my downfall album
coming september
[Music]
[Music]
bye